[Music]
the word
gamer can mean a lot of different things
to
a lot of different people you've got
your blood thirsty but
efficient killing machines
party's over no
there's your out of control rage-filled
try-hards
the soft-spoken mechanically gifted
psychopaths
and of course the clueless noobs who
always seem to end up
in the wrong place at the wrong time
but to most people a gamer is a basement
dweller who spends
hours each day playing video games brags
about how many virtual scalps they've
collected
and has a gaming channel to share their
exploits with the world
and in that sense michelle tactical
grandma statham
is a pretty typical gamer as you might
have guessed from her name
she's actually anything but typical
[Applause]
oh
found the one on the roof
so who the hell is this head clicking 56
year old golden girl
how did she turn her passion for one of
gaming's most notoriously unfriendly
franchises
into a growing tick-tock empire and how
does she consistently
destroy zoomers despite being
like three times their age
i just sniped this guy so hard
[Music]
all right guys before we dive into this
nutty ass nana's story i'm gonna ask
that you please like the video
subscribe to the channel and turn on
notifications
because i mean do you really want to
miss any more offbeats about these
bloodthirsty boomers
i didn't think so okay so just to hammer
the point home
tactical grandma is the literal
definition
of a gamer she lives in a basement
although it's her kids and not her
parents and it's not exactly the
basement you're probably picturing
technically it's not a basement we just
like to say that it's a split level
house
so like the stairs go up and you go
either up or down so we are the bottom
floor we just put a basement in down i
mean and we put a kitchen in down here
so we have our own kitchen our own
little living room and two little rooms
down here but yeah
her call of duty clips can be found on
practically every media platform that
exists
and just like the proper grandmother
that she is
she'll give you a forehead kiss good
night before she puts you to sleep
forever
oh my gosh i thought you were next to me
i'm like running next to this guy and i
thought it was you so
how exactly did a sweet grandmother of
two turn
into one of warzone's deadliest snipers
well the seeds of grandma's eventual
streaming career were planted back in
the 1970s with the atari 2600 where she
spent countless hours playing classic
games
like pong and crackpots with her family
fast forward a couple of decades and
grandma found herself married with kids
but gaming wasn't a pastime that she'd
left with her childhood
no grandma continued to use it as both a
competitive outlet
and a bonding activity when we had kids
we had nintendo so we played all the
nintendo games
mario super mario mario party a lot of
sports games
oh yeah my family's so competi i mean
growing up we were competitive i played
competitive soccer my whole life
grandma and her husband also turned
games into an opportunity to spend
quality time together when the kids went
to bed
out came the controllers that's [ __ ]
couple goals
my husband plays this is what we did
this was our date nights when our kids
were little we couldn't afford to go
anywhere so we would just play video
games i mean this is what we did
but as the years went by grandma found
herself grappling with increasing
pain caused by arthritis in her thumbs
and it became so bad that she had to
hang up her controller for good
it probably like slowly started probably
about 10 years ago so but i would keep
playing and just play through the pain
but it just got
too bad like it's like this joint there
so like if you move even just that
motion hurts
like controller just wasn't gonna work
anymore so i had to switch away
but as they say when one door closes
another
is bound to open and so grandma's family
suggested that she give pc gaming a try
instead
now learning to use a mouse and keyboard
after a lifetime of using a controller
is no easy feat just ask half the kids
in my siege lobbies
but despite her initial reservations
grandma
threw herself head first into the
challenge i was really nervous and
really kind of
afraid to do it but i just i think i
think what i started on was
um fortnite like the rumble
mode in fortnight cause you just keep
coming back and who cares if you like
you don't have teammates
that care if you die really because
everybody's just trying to just play and
shoot so i
i did a lot of fortnite rumble just
trying to figure out the keys
as grandma became more comfortable with
her new gaming setup
she found herself drawn to streamers
like tim the tatman and
sigma and it was around that time that
her family suggested that she give
streaming a shot in the beginning i
never even wanted to watch people play
video games i thought it was stupid to
watch people play video games but then
it came up on my feet on facebook and i
started watching people
and so they knew i was watching people
and then both my husband and son they
were
they were like you should stream and i'm
like but no one's gonna want to watch
someone my age
play and i'm not that great and they're
like we don't have anything to worry
about if no one's gonna watch you might
as well do it
but grandma decided that if she was
gonna stream she wasn't gonna do it
playing cutesy games designed for filthy
casuals
now grandma wanted to get a bit sweaty
and
clicks and faces so like many of the
streamers she followed
grandma set her sights on first person
shooters like apex and escaped from
tarkov
and to her surprise there were people
interested enough in following her
adventures
now initially grandma divided her time
between streaming and watching her
grandkids but once the covet 19 pandemic
hit north america in early 2020
grandma found herself with enough free
time to fully commit to streaming
we couldn't go anywhere so what else was
i gonna do
so it kind of was like well we're not
going anywhere i would i would stream
for like four hours take a break hang
out with the grandbabies and
my youngest lived in hawaii but she was
quarantined here with us at home
she came home she's like if i'm gonna be
stuck he could work remotely
so she was here so i'd spend time with
all them and then stream again in the
evening for four hours
and while grandma was certainly having
fun braining people
in games like apex it was in march that
she was introduced to what would
soon become her primary hunting ground
one that she
wasn't totally unfamiliar with the first
call of duty came out we got it we
started playing in every we've gotten
every call of duty since they've come
out and played and that was our date
nights my husband and i we would go we
didn't we used to live in the
in the country and had no internet so
some friends of ours would let us use
their office so we'd pack up we had two
xboxes
two portable little tvs we'd go pack up
go to their office and go online and
play
so i've just always played call of duty
so it's been one of my favorite games
to play that's why i i still love it i
know a lot of people get tired of it but
i still love it
adam inside
but no matter how experienced she was at
cod juggling both
the game and chat definitely took some
getting used to
just wanted to say that every time you
come up on my fya p
page brightness let's go
you guys didn't see that did you
occasional mishaps aside though
grandma's viewers quickly began to take
notice of the fact that no matter how
she felt about her own skills
her aim was way better than just average
but it was when her husband began
uploading her highlights to tick-tock
that tactical grandma really began to
catch the attention
of zoomers everywhere
oh my gosh
[Music]
as her popularity on tick tock continued
to explode
it wasn't long before this frag hungry
nana
started making waves on other platforms
tactical grammar
i only know a little bit but apparently
she's a really good
call of duty player and she's very old
of course she's 58 i mean okay well yeah
now
as is always the case with anyone who
makes it big clapping cheeks for a
living
not everyone that tunes into your stream
is going to be there to support you
and being that this head clicking queen
is actually a 56 year old grandmother of
two
it is simply incomprehensible to certain
mouth-breathing naysayers that she's
well better than they are i just had it
on a comment yesterday it's like oh i
can see you can see in the in the
reflection that
someone else is holding the controller
and playing i'm like
for one on my mouse and keyboard and i
don't know what you're talking about but
i get that all the time there's not me
playing they're like it's your grandson
playing and like
he's a prodigy then because he's one but
okay and and i think that females get
that
anyways but then you add my age on top
of it it gets
it's a little more yes you know you get
people that come in that or
go make me a sandwich or make me cookies
you know
the whole but to her credit grandma
doesn't let the occasional hater take
away from her enjoyment of going live
eight hours a day a routine that
involves her not only
decimating her opponents but just about
every single granny stereotype out
he's still up there i can see his gun
sticking out
thank you there's still one up there
but for grandma it's not just about
silencing her critics
laughing in the face of stereotypes or
fondly reminiscing over her
every glorious frag no instead
she's relishing every opportunity she's
had to build a
positive community that encourages
people to connect with each other
over their love of video games like i
started streaming
on a whim kind of thing because they
told me to but really why i continue to
do it is the community
i will try to create a place that's
super welcoming
super encouraging super like we're just
there to support each other especially
through the pandemic it's been a really
tough
time for a lot of people so we've just
created a place where people can come
and hang out
share kind of what's going on in their
life and we're just kind of there for
each other
and while there's no question that
grandma has personally benefited from
her newfound clout
and the community she's built she's also
using her platform to help raise money
for worthy causes like saint jude's
children's hospital
truthfully watching anyone be good at a
game you enjoy
is entertainment enough but watching
someone who by all definitions
shouldn't be able to do or even be
interested in doing what grandma does at
her age
is impressive as hell as an older than
average streamer
grandma is part of a growing movement to
normalize the fact that
older people can and do play video games
and can even become good enough to turn
their digital adventures
into a viable career why my family's
super supportive but everybody else
outside of it kind of looks me like you
play video games for a living and people
pay you i'm like i know it's weird right
and
sure not all of the older gamers out
there are gonna be insane at shooters
but that's perfectly okay at the end of
the day no matter what game
grandma or any of her fellow seniors
choose to enjoy
they are ushering in a reality that'll
benefit all of us in the long run
one where a video game savvy
grandparents isn't viewed as some
freakish novelty but a simple fact
of life yeah oh
what the heck i just no way i don't know
how i got that but i downed him
holy moly he's gonna think i'm cheating
then you should hear these kids man when
i can play like
sheesh you should hear this [ __ ] dude
it's crazy
yo yo and last night we were attacking
it around and i just like literally two
rounds in a row i just [ __ ] like
back to back three k's and you should
hear these kids in the
ryan and his friends at the comps man
it's so funny dude he's 28.
he's a [ __ ] fossil and like he's
[ __ ] just he's got
sick aim like holy [ __ ] like he's
destroying kids